house of vegas pride is a three-day
multicultural pride festival with day
and night parties fashion shows and
plenty of good conversations here to
tell us all about this wonderful event
our nicole williams who is with the
festival and deborah story with blasian
blasian blasey on one of the clothing
lines at the show welcome you to nicole
let's start with you tell us more about
the festival well the festival is a
cultural professor like you said that's
for the summer i implement the local
lgbt community with fundraiser events
where they get to keep all the profits
from the proceeds that they make as well
as having a national
platform for the tourists to come to
vegas and have a stay and play resort
style living vegas pride and it's
happening mostly at the artisan hotel
yes it's all happening at the artisan
hotel you can stay there and just
indulge in the pool the patio the lounge
the the day parties and everything i
love it because you've got music you've
got fashion you've got conversation and
deborah let's talk about some of the
fashion you have some ladies here with
us today what are we going to look at
actually we're going to look at my fall
winter collection some of the pieces
from my collection and sydney
is going to be the first model here she
comes
and she is wearing my
fiery sequin
fall winter collection that is gorgeous
it kind of reminds me of hunger games a
little bit a little katniss everdeen yes
absolutely we're just missing the fire
yeah she is stunning and it sparkles
with the lights here in the studio i
imagine outside of the sun you were
saying
she is gorgeous beautiful who's our next
model nya
is also in one of my fall winter
collection she is in gold
and black food wow
stunning stunning now what is the back
story on the name
actually blaseon collection came from
blasian that's where it originated from
since i am black in asian descent
and i just pretty much put a little
twist to it made a little
european these are just these are
gorgeous outfits this is the stunning
outfit so what other volunteer work do
you ladies do here in town in las vegas
i do a lot yes i know
i volunteer with las vegas pride i am
the urban editor for urban content for
the las vegas pride
i also am the lgbt liaison for the
national action network las vegas
chapter out here in las vegas two very
busy entrepreneurs now this with the
weekend events a lot going on is it
family friendly stuff for kids as well
yes there there is actually on sunday is
our community health and wellness fair
which is taking place at the pearson
center from 11 a.m to 2 p.m on that
sunday so we are actually going to be
promoting hiv mobile testing so we'll
have the aids healthcare foundation out
there we're going to have an adult
kickball game we'll have
community activities for the kids and a
job fair uh for people to come out and
apply and you can come as you are you
don't have to come dressed in a suit you
have everything covered ladies thank you
so much for joining us it's going to be
such a great event house of vegas pride
is friday august 20th through sunday
august 22nd and great job for our models
amazing job more information go to
vegaspridehouse.com las vegas now we'll
be right back